உங்கள் அப்பிட்டாராங்க
ரம்பு ஒரேவர் அல்லது இன்னும் எவ்வளவு பெரிய பாதிப்பாடுகிறீர்கள் பாருங்கள்
அவன் நியாயமா, அனியாயமா என்று தெரியவில்லை நாங்கள்
அரம் தேஷங்களில் யாருக்கு முன்னால இருக்கும் பிரிஸினினிட்டு
ஏற்படுத்தி வைச்ச அமரிக்காவுடைய ஏற்பேஸ் அங்கிருந்து இரானுக்கு பாம் போடுறான்
இரான் திருப்பி எடிக்கது அரம் தேஷத்து, அமரிக்கா மேல் அவனால அவ்வளவு
ரெய்னி மிசானி இல்லை அரம் தேஷத்து பாரிக்கிறேன்
இவன் என்ன பண்ணா, அரம் தேஷம் துபை என்ன பண்ணித்து
பணத்துக்காக தன்னே நாட்டு ஓயல் மேலையும் தன்னே நாட்டுயும் அமரிக்காவுடைய குவித்தான் பணத்துக்காக
ஒசம்ம பெண்ணாடனே, அமரிக்கன் கொண்டரைட்டர், ஆனால அரமிக்
இது நம்முடைய அறிவால புரிந்துகொள்ள விஷயம் இல்லை
யார்? ஏன் இவன் பாதிக்கப்பட்டும்? ரோடில் போடுவேன், துப்பாக்கிச் சூட்டில்
நேற்று நம்ம பையா ஒத்தன், நாக்பூரில் யோட்டியா போராட்டதுக்கு வேண்டாம்
அந்தக் கட்டத்தை இடிக்கும்போது, முகாயின் சிங்க் வந்து
நான் ரப்பர் புருண்டு, குலிஸ் துட்டுது, இப்போது அவனுக்கு 82லிருந்து எத்தனை வருடங்கள் ஆன்று, இது 35 வருடங்கள் ஆன்று
அவனுடைய ஒரு கண்ணு குருடா இருக்கிறது, நன்றாக மிகவும் பாவர்ப்புல் ஆளு
அவன் பொல்லுட்டேஷனா வந்திருந்தால் என்னிடம் இருக்கலாம்
தேவெந்தன் பண்ணவீசுவின் தொகுதையில் சீப்பினேஸ்டாகக்கூட இருக்கலாம், முடிந்துவிட்டது எல்லாரும் பெரியும்
இப்போது இதை என்ன செய்தான், கூட்டத்தில் இருந்தான்
தேவெந்தன் பண்ணவீசுவின் தொகுதாகக்கூட்டது எல்லாரும் பெரியும்